downstairs and nobody had told me i
still had lipstick on oh
no no right before right as well as i
was outside then like right
once i came downstairs you were like
yeah you have lipstick on and i was like
oh from the nose down you look like the
joker i was chatting with the suits i
mean that's how much you had on that's
the most i've ever gotten to chat with
suits yeah and it was just smeared
lipstick all over my mouth it didn't
even hit my lips it was a whole it was
like up to his nose oh and i also i got
i'm not kidding i had a bruise the next
day on my cheek do you know why
joe rogan
[Laughter]
birthday party afterwards and segura
first of all tom segura what a [ __ ]
idiot
why because because i show up there and
he goes hey i want to introduce you to
the asians
so he would like people that work there
he's like this is my asian friend
i don't i'm not lacking
asian he's like no no you this is
important he went all throughout the
[ __ ] thing people that were working
there hey you know my asian so i don't
know why he does that but then he did
that and then the second thing is i see
ali wong and i want to say hi to her but
then i saw that shadowy figure there it
was joe
and he just
i thought he was going to headbutt me
but he came in for a kiss and i swear to
god i had a bruise right here
he's a really strong kiss but it was
really nice to see joe it was nice to
see everyone there at the party but i
was only there for a second
maybe an armpit kiss yeah yeah
no he he just came to to say hi
but he did give you an underhook it was
more like i think it was an attempt at a
hug yeah yeah but then event it was
really just an underhook and then it was
a fireman's carrier and so and then i
put him in a clinch like
anderson silva rich franklin kind of
classic awkward hug it was like a weird
like hu it wasn't it was like it was a
clinch and we got into a clinch is what
happened
um but it was but he loves us yeah but
he was late he was sweet yeah it was fun
i love him and we had we had a blast
yeah it was like fun it was fun uh but
then me and the losers
went to uh korean barbecue you guys left
me and santino were so pissed because i
all of a sudden you were gone insulting
i was like hi where's bobby we're the
losers well i have two in-cell friends
that they're not in-cells but they're
like my types one of them is esther
povick's fiancee
i know
and jean hong
it's not that we're in cells i'm just
saying that if dave king me and jean
hong lived in
are you going to cut this out no no i
was just if we looked at the most alpha
inside i know we're alpha but if we were
lived in dayton ohio seriously and we
were all like working at a lab
right
with all those people they would it's
just that we we decided
that we are going to do show biz and
we're talented well i'm not saying me
i'm just saying yeah i have a talent and
um
you know we we are able to get girls
but um
but we were all at uh augusty
and just eating food it was great
in-cell nation insulting good band-aid
yeah yeah it's funny because gene i was
like hey gene do you need a plus one for
everything he says i don't need a plus
one i'm gonna die alone gilbert
yeah that's what i'm saying that's my
thing he's so happy that's why i love
him
he's like one of my best friends i love
him because we have the same he's the
best thing of like you know
we're we're losers
but winners too you know he's not no he
has more confidence yeah yeah yeah his
crew people he hangs with is
next level i don't want to talk about it
but anyway um
even david king's next level you know
what i mean
but um
so thank you for everyone thanks guys so
we have a guest coming today um his name
is anwar faham
and uh anwar is he here yet
[Music]
brooklyn
usa
every day has summer got you feeling
sweaty certainly has that's right babes
cool down with brook lyndon's 15